[Inaudible].
See about something, about what Childs, what did that? Wow.
He broke up. Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, Whoa. Wow.
Did it hurt when you fell from heaven? Because I'm looking at an angel.
Do you like sleeping? Me too? We should do it together some time. Oh,
I'm not really feeling myself today, so maybe I can feel you instead. Well,
I never, you just met this fun young lady. Oh my golly.
Miss Molly. Well, you can call me Molly. Anytime you like.
Well, man, it was too soon. Indeed. My apologies.
It's quite all right. It's chilly out. Would you fancy my jacket?
Well, only if it's boyfriend material.
I mean, um, no, thank you.
[Inaudible].
All right. I'm just going to get right down to the real nitty gritty.
Would you like to go study with me? No, I,
you spoken for something? No, just not interested,
but I did meet him when I said I wanted to feel that pub she's a real angel from
heaven, Matt.
Oh, wow.
Thank you.
[Inaudible].
Well, I never.